ويواجه القطاع الصحي في مناطق الشمال
السوري المنكوبه بالزلزال صعوبه كبيره في
التعامل مع الاعداد الهائله من الاصابات
والحالات الحرجه وتضم المناطق الخاضعه
للسيطره المعارضه في شمال غرب سوريا ما
يزيد على 500 مؤسسه صحيه ظل اغلبها في
الخدمه بالاعتماد على دعم المانحين
الدوليين
261 من تلك المنشاه الطبيه توجد في محافظه
ادلب وتتوزع بين مشاف وعيادات ومراكز
رعايه مختصه لكن تلك المؤسسات الصحيه
جميعها تواجه نقصا في الكادر الطبي بعد ان
غادرها نحو
70% من العاملين فيها بفعل الحرب بحسب
الصليب الاحمر الدولي ما جعل طبيبا واحدا
يخدم نحو عشره الاف شخص من اصل ما يقرب من
اربعه ملايين نسمه وفقا لتقديرات اداره
القطاع الصحي في مناطق شمال غرب سوريا كما
المشافي في تلك المناطق منذ ما قبل كارثه
الزلزال من نقص حاد في المستلزمات الصحيه
الاساسيه كالاسعافات الاوليه ومواد
التخدير وصفائح المستخدمه لكسور العظام